RETO MEIER: Google
Cloud Next 2017
hosted a plethora of talks
detailing the future of cloud.
If you didn't get a chance to
catch Evan Anderson's session
on DevOps with App
Engine, stay tuned,
because here's the recap.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLT MCANLIS: When you've
got a DevOps system in place,
the biggest enemy you have
is a concept called toil.
RETO MEIER: Toil is
the work you do today
that you'll need to
do again tomorrow,
which is a problem,
because it scales linearly
with system growth.
And it's work that
doesn't need much judgment
or creative problem-solving.
COLT MCANLIS: Now, the
antidote to toil is automation.
As you know, there's a lot
of data center automation
solutions out there already.
Some, like a Chef,
Salt, and Puppet,
refer to themselves
as fleet management,
while others, like a Kubernetes,
Mesos, and Docker Engine,
are typically called
container orchestration.
Both sets of solutions do
effectively the same things.
They help you manage and
deploy images and build
so that you don't go crazy.
But there is another layer that
removes even more of your toil
and lets you take
your application
management to the next level.
And that, my friends,
is App Engine.
But first, here is Dickerson's
hierarchy of reliability,
created by the Googlers working
on the Healthcare.gov project.
Each layer moves you
from things which
are required towards things that
are just really nice to have.
RETO MEIER: This shot
helps us understand
what we need in order to
properly provide reliability
to a service,
which, at its core,
is the whole goal behind DevOps.
This is where App
Engine fits in.
When it comes to
all the tools you
need to provide reliability,
App Engine has you covered.
Let's start with monitoring.
Because App Engine is a
platform as a service,
all your top-level
metrics are already logged
and available-- things like
request latency and queue times
are automatic and can be
tracked across the application
as a whole, or at specific
URLs without needing
to write any application code.
Just open Stackdriver,
and all this data
is exposed alongside monitoring
and inspection tools,
so you can export additional
metrics directly, or from logs,
and align them with
your instance data.
COLT MCANLIS: Next
is incident response,
AKA how fast can we get back
to normal when things go wrong?
App Engine is designed
to automatically retain
previously deployed
versions and all audit logs.
When something bad
happens, you can roll back
to an earlier deployment
in a single action.
And App Engine will handle
all of the traffic splitting
and deployments to make
this happen seamlessly.
RETO MEIER: Then there's
testing and release.
Chances are you don't want to
test everything in production.
Accordingly, App Engine supports
multiple concurrent deployed
versions and gives
you control needed
to stage releases and balance
traffic between builds.
Not to mention App
Engine has integrations
with a number of CI tools, like
Jenkins, Travis, and Circle CI.
COLT MCANLIS: Which brings
us to capacity planning.
App Engine makes capacity
planning magical.
Automatic scaling,
including scale
to zero for unused
versions, reduces
the need for capacity
planning and any reservations.
RETO MEIER: Finally, at the
very top of the pyramid is UX.
This one is pretty
straightforward.
Stackdriver covers a whole
suite of UX opportunities
to display your data and
monitoring information
in a bunch of different ways.
And you can also build
your own dashboards
to get focused
insight on the numbers
that matter most to you.
So make sure you follow the
hierarchy of reliability,
and check out the recording
of Evan's full session
to see some practical examples
of using App Engine to stretch
your DevOps dollar further.
If you want more recaps
on great Next content,
make sure to check out
the rest of our playlist,
and don't forget the Next
world tour coming soon
to a city near you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]